[Music]  single strike could reshape our world  and the only thing that can stop it is  science it wasn't until a couple hundred  years ago leave and knew that asteroids  existed finding asteroids before they  find us is critical we use telescopes to  take pictures of the night sky a moving  point of light reveals an asteroid we  use this radio dish antenna from the  Raider echo we can determine their shape  orbit and size preventing an asteroid  strike requires engineers of every  discipline and a lot of teamwork no idea  is too crazy  [Music]  IMAX invites you  to learn about the science  the technology  and the heroes who are Earth's secret  weapons  [Music]  you  you